give us one that you you're pretty
confident about give us one that you
would say if I were to change one thing
about our educational system this is the
one that I can confidently speak on
broadly and the way I would change the
science is another thing but let me say
broadly
I would say
that I would de-emphasize
the value the educational system places
on what grade you got yeah
and figure out ways to assess or rather
to promote or to nurture
your
enthusiasm for learning
and because of this what happened you
know what happens there are people who
get high grades these are the people who
pay attention in class and all their
homeworks are handed in on time and they
might become valedictorian and
however if you look at the biggest
shakers and movers in society in
practically any field none of them were
valedictorians the most if you've read a
lot of business so you know CEOs were
never the top of their class or
entrepreneurs whenever the top of their
class they were too distracted by other
thoughts and ideas and and look at
Richard Branson who his Headmaster said
you'll either be in prison or be a
millionaire that's right the end of a
billionaire that's right because he was
not following these educational rules
about what would enable a teacher to
judge that you will go far and my grades
in school were pretty average
pause they were average no teacher at
any time in my life K through 12 16 and
20. okay
would have ever said see that guy Tyson
watch him he'll go far
none of them even though I was all into
the universe no one said that no one
would have said that had you asked had
you walked into the classroom and I'm in
the class and asked the teacher who's
going to go far in this class I would
have never shown up on their beloved Any
teacher yet it's not like I was a late
bloomer I've known I was interested in
the universe since I was nine and at age
11 you asked me what I want to be when I
grow up that annoying question adults
always asking I said I want to be an
astrophysicist and I was in the
astronomy club and I walked dogs and
used that money walked other people's
dogs use that money to buy my first
telescope at age my first at age 14 and
I had cameras I had a dark room who
knows what a dark room is anymore but
that's why uh produced all my
photography all of this was going on and
it doesn't show up on a grade in my
school and so the teacher doesn't see
that they don't know it they don't even
care they just care what grade you've
got yep and so here I am growing myself
and had this whole library of books my
parents would buy remaindered books they
cost 50 cents they just they didn't know
any science but they saw a science book
or a math book they bought it for I had
the biggest library of any middle
schooler there ever was okay so all of
this is going on and in high school I
went on an expedition to to to Scotland
to view the stone monuments that are
similar to Stonehenge but many are not
charted and I was on expedition to chart
them I was the localist I was the
astronomer brought in with
archaeologists and anthropologists all
this is happening
I spent a summer in an astronomy Camp
living nocturnally in the desert in the
Mojave Desert while I was in high school
none of that shows up as a grade and
what I'm all I'm saying is
a person is so much more than the
numerics of their GPA
that if you only focus on a GPA you will
lose people
there'll be people who will go
unrecognized unsupported
unidentified in the school system how do
we grade the other part though how do we
great like that's that's the challenge
yeah I don't know how you would now try
to encode ambition or drive these are
have more passion especially these are a
little more abstract and maybe the
school rather than judging you whether
you have passion yeah they should find
ways to instill passion within you and
then you're graded by how much more
passion you had after the class than you
did before rather than how much you
walked in there with well let me ask you
this so here's the other question so for
me having ran a sales organization for
20 some years I'll see somebody come in
and I used to say man that guy's a great
talker he's going to do great in sales
one month later he quits and he goes to
the next and the next and you'll see
another guy like well it just means you
suck at evaluating but but I did you're
right but but you're right no I'm just
no no but you but but he's trying to
clown you but he's like no you're right
I agree with you as as a newer sales
leader I did then when I learned we
build a forty thousand Insurance Agency
company Nationwide and I'm the founder
of it so I learned how to lock onto the
right people here's a question for you
so what should be the key indicator
maybe two or three indicators to say
this 16 year old kid this 14 year old
kid this 17 year old kid could one day
do something very big in their lives or
is it too early to tell you it could
surely be too early to tell which is why
you always want to
present opportunities to people
throughout their lives to see if they'll
jump on them modify them make them fit
their lives all I will say is when
assessing the promise and performance
of a student
you need to look at more than their GPA
I don't mind standardized exams I don't
mind you want to give somebody an IQ
test I don't have a problem with any
test but the moment you administer a
test
and then use that against the person
because they didn't score high enough on
this test above some threshold that you
have cut off and only then do you give
them opportunities this is using
Educational Systems and tools against
the progress of students rather than for
them when I was in sixth grade that was
still contained in an elementary school
I was not in what they called the
smartest class because they they they
were identified by the system and and
they took French
they took a foreign language and I said
well why can't I take a form well you're
not you're you you don't belong in that
class okay you got to go in the second
class and they would given opportunities
that I really wanted to have
and I was denied it because some
educational construct declared that I
was Unworthy of it
and so uh that I've been thinking about
that ever since because I was already
ambitious as a kid
I I I I don't this isn't a pushback but
it's like
Pat was a 1.8 GPA student
but and your your subject was math right
like if you could have just dedicated
all your time to math I would do math
with you made me do it or not I don't
know what kind of grades you got
sometimes somebody tells me you did okay
but I got a mixture of A's B's and C's
which average to B I guess my point is
like but it all worked out okay meaning
like you're the most famous
astrophysicist in the world it worked
out so that was horrible at everything
else he's amazing at business math it
worked out I was always like an actor
thespian here I am so it worked out no
no no no no no no no it's not just it
worked out no
somewhere in there you are standing up
after you've been knocked down multiple
times that's not just it worked out
that's where your drive is your grit
your ambition Your Capacity to recover
from any forces operating against your
your all of this so it's not just it
worked out I'm where I am not because of
my educational past but in spite of it
God is my point so you're saying the
school system should have done should do
a better job identifying what you're
super super passionate about or let you
double down on that versus useless no no
that's being more specific that I'm
prepared to land at this moment yeah but
what a school should say is
don't Reserve all your highest Praises
for the people who get the highest
grades do some other searching in the
total life of the person suppose there's
someone who who is who in in middle
school or high school is taking care of
the younger kid babysitting walking dogs
doing this uh shopping do it and figured
out a way to make that efficient and
I've created a budget for the family
because they couldn't figure that look
what that is oh my gosh the person is
figuring out life and no one was there
to train them that's ambition that's
some of it is the the necess the what do
you call it the um Necessities the
mother of invention or or in order to
survive you got to be get clever okay
but these are tests of us throughout our
lives if you're a deadbeat sitting at
home watching TV and and you don't have
good grades I got nothing for you at
that point
but take a look at the total package
because in life the total package is
what's going to matter okay so let me
let me ask you a question I'm going to
teach I teach a couple this is going to
show up in this education book I have
teacher comment I still have my report
cards uh Neil is um should
um
less social involvement and more
academic diligence is in order
what they're saying is my social energy
my social energy was a negative in that
classroom by the way I wasn't purposely
disruptive it was more a gurgling of
energy just you know okay that was a
negative
and meaning you would socialize with our
students you were talkative you were
energetic I passed notes and things yeah
that was bad rather than saying there
could be some value to this later on he
might become a communicator because he's
communicating with all these people at
all these different times no one is
thinking that all they can see is the
grade in their class that's why none of
the teachers would have said look at him
he'll go far Neil in your class by the
way I asked this question about two
months ago and it was incredible hearing
the answer what does the valedictorian
of your high school do for work today
did they meet and exceed the expectation
if I tell you 95 percent of the
responses was no yeah of course it was
oh no no no but but going back by the
way that's not true for my valedictorian
but who was yours what did he do what
did he or she do he was co-founded
regeneron
um
the biomed company yeah he was my
valedictorian my Year from the Bronx
High School that's insane what number
did you finish the Bronx High School of
Science
um there were about 700 graduates I they
don't number it below 10 but I was
probably 300 350th got it who else was
very successful in your school outside
of him
uh he and I have our names on the school
wall
um I have to think about okay so then
that means you we don't so did you did
you see any signs of genius or something
different about him where you said this
guy could do something in his life or no
at the time yeah
um he was very ambitious I mean he did
science fair projects which again are
extra curricular additional on top on
top of the grade for the thing and uh
here's something interesting he did
because he competed I think if I
remember correctly competed in the
famous Westinghouse science challenge
search and did very well in that when he
became regeneron that
that science Talent shirt has changed
quote ownerships over the years and now
there's the regeneron prize out of the
monies that they have invested in it so
so uh that I so I'm just saying if
you're just looking at grades that's the
person who is trying to impress you
here's here's the measure I got it for
you ready
uh if you got a 97 on your exam
instead of a hundred
are you gonna complain to your teacher
are you going to complain if it's like
hand graded and are you gonna complain
we don't okay it's 97's just as good as
100 I don't care if you're going to
complain that means you're after the
grade more than you're after learning
and at some level valedictorians are
after the grades
and that
ask anyone who's 30 and older in this
world when was the last time someone
wanted to know your GPA they won't even
be able to remember
it never comes up at work it's are you
honest are you moral are you a hard
worker do you solve problems whole sets
of qualifications that are not encoded
in your GPA
or SAT score or AC same difference or
anything like that same difference so
how important are extracurricular
activities meaning like you might have
gotten been a b student but your captain
of the debate team or you're on the
football team or the wrestling team
captain of my wrestling oh were you
really yeah okay so I'm defeated by the
way in high school but but that's very
high news right it's not in Iowa okay
just to be clear there are places where
people were wrestling as a religion and
I was undefeated in a place where
wrestling is not a religion so so so
going back so I had these extra things
that was my rest of my life I did fun
thing I did things that that not only
were activities there were activities
that further grew my knowledge and
awareness of fields so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here